you're strong but I could snap my
fingers
and you'd all cease to exist with four
in time to see all the possible outcomes
did we win any
it's a small price to pay for salvation
[Music]
to all our amazing fans the truth is we
are here for you we got to thank you for
10 years of support and inspiration the
reason we're here
thank you for 10 years of the greatest
cosplay
standing in those long lines for Hall
age
reading the comics after you saw the
movie Twitter fights and it's all been
leading up to this thank you please just
thank you so much thanks for being so
incredible we couldn't have done any of
this without you
hey everybody is Charlie let's all snap
our fingers and break down some New
Avengers they released this Thanos Spa I
had to wait a little bit till the
footage wasn't quite as janky there's
usually like a cellphone version then
there's like a high quality version that
comes later so the cool thing about this
is I was gonna do a fan OHS backstory
video because he has a different
backstory in the movies than he does in
Marvel Comics and thankfully they just
released a Thanos centric TV spot that
deals with one of his most iconic
moments from the Infinity Gauntlet saga
I could snap my fingers and you'd all
cease to exist in the comics he just
snapped his fingers it was just like
this clever move like he had this goal
to accomplish erasing half of all life
in the universe to balance it for death
on her orders but it was a little more
jim Starlin winking at the audience
through Thanos his character like he
just holds his hand up in the air with
the gauntlet snaps his fingers and then
all over reality you see the Avengers
start to realize that something has
changed like wait a minute
where did everybody go but in the comics
the people that got erased were
remembered by the people that were still
left alive so he was effectively killing
them not wiping them from existence
because if that was true then everyone
would lose memory of the people that got
erased also really cool Doctor Strange
says that he used the time stone to try
and look into the future to see all
potential outcomes in the fight against
Thanos and by the sound of it when iron
man's like did we win in any of those
scenarios Doctor Strange is probably
gonna be like hell no we lost in every
single one but if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get all the Marvel videos there's gonna
be a whole bunch of stuff happening
between now and infinity war they
released that promo or they're like hey
everybody thanks so much for spending
all your money on our movies keep doing
that please I always love being
appreciated by big brands like Marvel
like they want to let you know they
really do appreciate you but I think
probably the best way to do that is from
the actors every once in a while just
reminding everyone hey thanks to the
fans like you were the
and why we are popular and just
continuing to churn out really awesome
movies show your thanks by continuing to
give us the steady stream of really cool
movies but the really important thing
about Thanos is back story is that they
revealed they basically cut it from the
movie it's like a giant deleted scene
maybe some of that will wind up making
the DVD the problem with a lot of the
Thanos deleted scenes is that most of
them were deleted before they filmed
them so it's not the same thing as a
normal deleted scene where you might
have Mark Ruffalo cracking wise with
Cherie when they're inside her lab like
there might just be a lot of improv
there that hit the cutting room floor
because it didn't work or it wasn't
funny when it comes to Thanos baby Groot
usually when they cut scenes is before
they get to the CG stage so it's much
earlier in the process but the Russos
recently told us exactly what those
deleted backstory scenes are and I don't
think this is a spoiler because these
were never intended to be in the movie
and I don't think they're gonna make the
DVD either it's just like context for
Josh Brolin when he was forming Thanos
his character so earlier Kevin Feige
said he's from a planet called Titan
which we all know same thing in the
comics that's no longer inhabited
because of things he thought he could
help prevent and he was not allowed to
do that what he feared most happened in
the planet and everybody on it basically
went extinct he vowed not to let that
happen again he thinks he sees the
universe going down the tubes he thinks
he sees life expanding outward unchecked
that will bring ruin he believes to the
universe and to that life so he's trying
to protect life by erasing half of it
but then the Russos couple bros totally
told us what the Cataclysm was that
destroyed the planet tightened that
Thanos is so upset about there's also
some extra stuff that they said in here
that has to do with people's powers and
their relative abilities so we'll talk
about that too they say and I'm quoting
them Thanos is a virtually
indestructible character who's stronger
than the hook and has invincible skin
he's from a planet called Titan many
years prior to the film his planet was
experiencing a cataclysmic shift they
were running out of resources
they were overpopulated Thanos made a
recommendation that they'd exterminate
half of the population randomly in order
to save the rest of the population of
course the other Titans rejected this
notion branded him a madman exiled him
in the
planet ended up dying so he's taken it
upon himself to go planet by planet
throughout the universe and wipe out
half of the population of each planet as
a way to correct things and bring the
universe back into balance once he hears
about the stones he realizes that if he
can get a hold of all the Infinity
stones he can control the entire
universe with the snap of his fingers he
could correct things permanently by
removing 50% of life from it so these
are the incredible stakes for our
characters if the Avengers were built
for anything is for stopping Thanos from
completing his goal so already if you're
a big comic book reader you know exactly
how they changed his backstory they've
worked in that iconic finger-snap and
made it a much bigger part of his
backstory it was less of a whim like it
was in the comics and much more of an
idea that he had that was rejected that
led to the destruction of his people
they also confirm how powerful he is
relative to the other Avengers Hulk is a
really good example because he's like
the strongest Avenger even though Thor
technically has God level power people
could argue all day about who's more
powerful when they say unbreakable skin
- what'll probably happen is there'll be
some moment during the film well you'll
see someone try to shoot him with some
really hardcore bullet or a blast
that'll just bounce right off of him
even without the Infinity Gauntlet he's
one of the most powerful people in the
Marvel comic book universe but that's
because death
brought him back to life he's died
multiple times but death will bring him
back so if he was strong then he died
he'll come back and get a huge power
level upgrade so that he can accomplish
whatever it is that death wants him to
do so they're just trying to balance the
MCU power levels a little bit everybody
is a little bit less powerful than they
are in the comics because it gets pretty
ridiculous in the comics but the big
thing about his backstory that they
changed is is that Thanos grew up as a
child on Titan everybody thought that he
was weird because he carried the deviant
gene so the deviant is part of the
Eternals races sort of like this
offshoot it gets into some crazy Jack
Kirby fourth-world stuff that he did at
Marvel so the Eternals is sort of like a
fourth world type story like the new
gods of DC Marvel has a version of that
fan oohs is descended from their race
most of them look like normal people but
because he carried the deviant gene he
came out looking like this purple thumb
that people kept making fun of when they
released pictures of him for the first
time while he was growing up he also
started to
hallucinate a girl that became his best
friend like his imaginary best friend
that was later revealed to be the cosmic
entity death they just followed him
around used him as a tool
he eventually fell in love with her and
realized who she really was but as a
child growing up she was just a
companion that would follow him around
and egg him on to do really messed-up
stuff like hey why don't you why don't
you tried dissecting this animal here
why don't you kill this person over here
so you slowly see this totally normal
boy who's really bright he was a really
smart person slowly descend into madness
and embrace the idea of death like he
fell in love with death he left height
and went on a bunch of pirate adventures
eventually started leading his own crew
gathered his own forces came back
destroyed the planet tight so in the
comics he destroyed his own race on
purpose instead of like the movie where
he tried to save them but it's more of a
tragic backstory you can kind of see how
the movies trying to humanize him just a
little bit more like oh you know he
tried to save his planet even though his
plan really is mad and I love the way
that they do say that he was branded a
madman as in the mad Titan but hopefully
that explains what his deleted backstory
scenes are not gonna see those in the
movie maybe they'll talk about them on
the DVD they'll probably be a couple of
fan OHS featurettes that they'll release
when we get closer to but there'll be
plenty more infinity war this week just
leave all your bonus video requests in
the comments below
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big video Paul Bochy oh
please private message me so I can get
your contact details new flash episode
posting later tonight's that should be
up in a couple hours
but click here for my premiere video and
click here for brand new flash thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome see you guys